Let's see here.
Let's go to our caller from the seven three
one area code.
Who's calling today from seven three one.
David, let me.
Yes, it is.
Who's this?
This is David from Jackson, Tennessee.
Love it.
What's going on?
So I was watching a clip from the same scene
as you show the other day.
And he made a comment that I took slight issue
with.
And I was wondering if I could get your opinion
on it.
Sure.
I mean, I'm going to have to take your word
that you're you're quoting it accurately,
but go ahead.
Basically, he was talking about some right
wing commentator I can't remember the name
of.
And he said when it comes to right wing commentators,
it's essentially you sometimes they'd ask
the question, is this person evil or stupid
or most of the time basic that I agree with.
Yeah.
And.
Well, I don't.
I can understand where he's coming from because
I look at a guy like Michael Knowles, for
example.
I think he can intentionally misrepresent
certain things and I can see why he would
see Sonoike bad as evil.
Or you can look at him like Matt Walsh also
on The Daily Wire.
And I could see why you would think he's maybe
less than intelligent.
But I honestly think Ben Shapiro, I think
he's very intelligent and I think that he
you know, I don't think that he is actually
trying to misdirect his audience.
I think he believes that conservative economics
is the way to go.
And I think it's kind of unfair to refer to
someone like him as evil one.
So maybe stupid is a pejorative, but if he
really believes conservative right wing economics
is the way to go and we know that it's not
from having, you know, 120, 150, 180 years
of evidence to suggest that we don't have
to say that he's stupid, but we could say
he's wrong on the facts.
Right.
Like, if we were able to say Shapiro's factually
wrong, that tax cuts for the rich stimulate
the economy.
He doesn't have to be evil and stupid is a
bit of an ad hominem.
But we could say he's just wrong.
Right?
Could we call it ignorance?
Yeah, I would say that's fine.
Okay.
So I think maybe stupid is too pejorative.
But what we're talking about is ignorance
to the facts.
And I think in that sense, it's sort of getting
to what's going on.
Yeah, it just it bothered me a little bit
just because, like I said, I'm from Tennessee.
Yeah.
And even though I'm a progressive, I have
tons of friends and family who are conservative.
And my dad is probably the smartest person
I personally know.
And he's a massive Ronald Reagan fan and all
that.
But then it baffles me that he's so intelligent
and I still believe that.
But I think my dad's a great guy and he's
very smart.
Well, he may he very well may be.
But is it possible that because of your dad's
ideology, he may be selectively ignoring certain
facts in order to keep his ideology neat and
tidy?
Yeah.
Wouldn't make him a bad person.
Yeah, I think I see what you're saying, but
honestly, I think everybody does get a little
bit.
I guess you could say conservatives do that
more, but I think that's just human nature.
It is.
No, there's no denying that that I agree with.
Yes.
But anyway, I was just I was wondering what
you thought about that.
I wasn't a big fan of that comment, but I
could see where it was coming from.
And I don't know.
It sounds like you don't like the tone, but
you mostly agree with the substance.
Yeah, I guess.
Now.
All right, my friend, thank you for the call.
I appreciate it.
David in Tennessee.
Wow.
A lot happening on the phone lines today.